I played the Opry last night I did the
Opry last night yeah uh me Chris Jansen
Riley green and Nelly did the for the
big friendsgiving for the big 98 here
wow perfect y dude you you you work hard
bro you do so much stuff jelly man I'm
just so blessed to be here though Theo
man you like I feel you there man it's
so different when I get to hang out with
you in Earnest because y'all were like
remember when it wasn't like this for me
and it's like this is all I wanted it to
be though so like now that I'm in it
like I just feel like I don't even want
to disrespect God like that kind of like
I prayed for this for so many years and
so many dude I I um I'm filming a
special for a television show uh CBS
Sunday mornings what they call it it's a
big big deal and I they took me back to
my old jail yesterday no oh wow the jail
that I found out I had my daughter in
like the jail I was in when she was
incarcerated they took me back to my old
Cale what was that like for one I walked
in there certain I wasn't going to be
emotional cuz I walked in so happy and
in such a good mood and I and dude
walked in the unit still happy we're
chatting I'm telling them Stories We
Walk upstairs and as soon as I walked in
that cell I cried like a Baby Dude I
mean like I lost it completely because
it was like every memory I'm getting
choked up now it's like every memory
from that jail cell like every song I WR
I spent like a year and a half in that
cell dog like the hearing I had a
daughter every song I wrote everything I
went through and you're just sitting
there like man this is unreal dude thank
you brother it's just sad it makes me
sad I mean it makes that make me sad but
it makes me yeah it's powerful to think
of somebody being caged up and then
being as free as you are no it's it's
unreal and I walk out of there I'm get
choked up too and I'm like I leave there
and go back to my old halfway house at
the men of valor I go see them boys and
it's like such a like humbling thing for
me and then I go do a show with Nelly
and Riley green and I'm on [__] the
biggest podcast on Earth the next day
like it's you and Rogan dude you know it
you know what I me I'm saying it's like
you know I'm just like man this is just
such a just I'm so like blessed do
that's why I do all the give back stuff
yeah it's like how could God bless me so
much and me not want to bless somebody
you know what I mean yeah and I know you
have a toy drive that's going on right
now that people can hit yeah any Walmart
Middle Tennessee okay they got a box
right there that you could just drop off
toys at the Box uh I'm going to put a
couple hundred grand up myself we're
going to do over 100,000 toys it'll be
the biggest one in Nashville I mean just
look who got behind us dude it's crazy
the Predators cocacola Hasbro uh the
Nashville fire department Walmart has
been a partner in this I mean man that's
so my dream is the next 5 years for this
to be a national thing that I do with
Walmart and we raise millions and
millions of toys for uh underprivileged
kids oh I love I go in there and buy
toys and put them in a box yeah yeah
just drop them right in the box man yeah
drop them right in the box and it's cool
cuz it's convenient we're all in and out
of Walmart All Season you know what I
mean so it's like all you got to do is
just buy an extra toy and dude going to
Walmart that used to be fun dude I'll
tell you a story you don't mind me
getting yeah you're right huh sometimes
there's nothing else to do on the road
but go to my daughter wanted to do this
yeah and she started this five six years
ago at a local bar in White House
Tennessee with her aunt where they would
just pick them up from the bar staff and
people and she'd go give away 2030 toys
she was doing this at N9 years old this
was her thought and I looked back at it
and when I got out of
jail give me a
second I came home like December
of
2009 I didn't have any money for toys
you know in the halfway house the men of
valor did a toy drive for the for the
guys that just came home and I remember
dropping off a
truck of toys I couldn't afford for her
Christmas and um I didn't even get to
meet her at that time I wasn't by Court
I wasn't even allowed to see her I just
got home wow
so her heart to want to do this toy
drive and then me to be able to be in a
situation to amplify it is like it's
really cool that is
amazing [__] I said I was going to cry
today I was like I'm not going to be
[__] emotional today I've had an
emotional week I got nominated for a
Grammy having a [__] weird couple
weeks damn dude you only dude I know
who's been nominated for a Graham and a
Grammy be honest I love you
so so and they split split one of them
with you yeah split one of them with
me oh yeah that's incredible bro but
it's crazy so it's like to see this
thing come to life as like I think
that's why I'm so passionate about
giving back to juvenile and I'm so
passionate about going to jails and
rehabs and singing for people and
investing in rehab facilities and like
like a meeting with our mayor and our
governor about the fitting all epidemic
and a plan and you know what I mean it's
like cuz these are the things that
affected my life you know what I mean
like the [__] that touches you the
closest to home yeah you know what I
mean so yeah we want to build a center
that's one of our goals next year is to
try to find some land to build like a
halfway like I don't know if it' be a
halfway house or a detox probably a
place where you could also have meetings
at you know where would you do it at I
don't know somewhere close enough like
somewhere here let me tell you this and
I'll say this on your show publicly
whatever I can do like whatever you want
to do like I don't care if we maybe we
do like a string of [__] shows or
something that I'll put together and
just donate the money or what like I'm
into that in a way you'll never
understand thanks like if you like if
nobody else like and this is what I say
off camera too I'll say it to you but
like not even just on some like raise
money [__] like I'll cut a [__] check
yeah same like I [__] I hate people
that go step just raise money you know
what I mean like if you're not that's
why I tell everybody don't worry I'm
putting money into this toy drive like
I'm G to write a big check because I'm
not just going to be a face of one yeah
my face can help bring more attention to
us that's the only reason I even talk
about this stuff we did philanthropy for
years and never spoke about it but I
realized that our platform's so big that
we can help bring attention and money to
the cause but it's still important to me
my daddy raised me man shut the [__] up
and cut a check you know what I mean
that's just something I learned from a
kid you know yeah no it's I appreciate
that man and we're going to do the same
thing we want to make yeah we just want
to do something a place I can go to
meetings you know where other guys can
go that'd be neat where people maybe we
could do a songwriter night where
songwriters come by and and play play
some songs with the guys or we'll do
something but yeah it's a big goal of
mine man it's just so important I just
so many friends of mine and myself so
many people in my own family just so
many people struggling that's why I
think I can feel when you talk about
that kind of stuff you know I know what
it's like to not be caged up like by
walls but to be caged up by even just
somebody's own their own life CED by
their own feelings you know man when
you're just locked inside of yourself
you know can't get outside of your own
head that's the worst prison I've been
to a lot of jails and the worst one on
earth is between the ears man yeah you
know